hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter 7 of
on freedom of choice and Psalm is going
to examine and analyze and then unravel
a difficulty that arises when we're
thinking about the power that the will
has to determine itself coupled with the
fact that it seemingly can also be
mastered by temptation so his student
raises this problem or a puzzle about
the will when it's overcome by
temptation the student says just as I'm
not able to deny what you prove so I'm
not at all able to affirm that the will
is stronger than temptation when it's
overcome by temptation as a matter of
fact we could say we're only looking at
the cases where the will is actually
overcome by temptation obviously when
it's not it must be stronger so what are
the problems
well willing to keep uprightness of will
for its own sake seems to be stronger
than temptation he says if the will to
keep uprightness were stronger than the
force then in willing what was in its
possession the will would resist more
strongly than temptation would insist
for I know other basis do I know that I
have a will that is more or less strong
than that I will or more or less
strongly so what
happening when I'm when I'm being
tempted he says is we when we willingly
give into temptation is that our will
isn't as strong and so temptation must
be stronger and maybe we get off the
hook for giving in to temptation then
and anthem says no that's that's not
really how it works and one of the
problems here is that you're using the
term we'll volum toss in an equivocal
way equivocal means that there's more
than one meaning to the term
traditionally it means that those
meanings are unrelated but in this case
they actually are related so if we were
using other vocabulary we might have an
stones saying these are analogically
related to each other or they're related
to each other by derivation it'd be that
as it may and some uses the term
equivocation and he tells us that will
has two different senses or meanings
what does that mean when we're using the
word will whether we realize it or not
we're talking about two different things
now in this treatise he talks about two
in other later treaties he will talk
about three we're not going to worry
about the third kind right here it's
enough to get this distinction down so
he says there's will as instrument for
willing and then there's will as used of
that very same instrument so let's take
a look at what he actually says he's
likening it to sight and he says that we
call sight the instrument for seeing
right and we also speak of sight as the
activity of that very instrument when we
use the instrument we might say the same
thing about any of the other senses
Anselm and other points will talk about
reason also being an instrument that we
use it's an instrument of the soul by
which we carry out reasoning and then
there's also the uses of reasoning right
so these are distinct from each other
but deeply connected
with each other so he says in the same
way will is said to be the instrument
for willing which is in the soul and
which we direct towards willing this or
that thing even as we direct sight
towards seeing various objects he says
will is also spoken of as the use of the
will which is the instrument for willing
just as sight is spoken of as the use of
sight which is the instrument for seeing
and he goes on and tells us that even
when we're not seeing we have sight that
is the instrument but only while we are
actually seeing do we have the activity
so likewise we always have the will as
instrument for willing that's part of
our basic equipment you might say
whether we're using it or not depends on
how we're using that instrument and
whether we are using that instrument now
what's the upshot of this well the will
is instrument is always the same thing
it's always one and it's always
possessing the same amount of strength
or capacity to will and so in this case
we can talk he says he says the
instrument the the will that I call
instrument for willing has an
inalienable strength which cannot be
overcome by any other force but when
we're talking about will as used now
this is multiple and interestingly it's
not just multiple by being directed to a
certain object it's also multiple by
being directed in certain occasions so
you know my willing to put on this tie
is a particular use of my will my
willing to keep this tie on or to loosen
it or tighten it those are all uses of
that instrument and maybe you know I'm
wavering in my mind I
no should I loosen it again so that you
know people can see me doing this and
it'll drive the example home and you
notice I'm not doing it right the will
to loosen the tie again is not as strong
as the will to merely talk about
loosening the tie in this case two
different wills right then I choose the
one over the other so that it's multiple
and it could be stronger or weaker so
when we're giving into temptation he
tells us here we go when the instrument
is presented with that which it wills
less strongly the will does not at all
desert what it wills more strongly and
when it is offered when it wills more
strongly to immediately abandons what it
wills less strongly right and so we can
say the will which we can call the act
of the instrument or the use of the
instrument is more or less strong
because it is done more or less strongly
it could be all the way down to almost
infinitesimal eWEEK right or it could be
using our entire range of capacities or
it could be somewhere in between so that
we're willing to to push through up to
this point and then we we quit what does
this have to do with being overcome by
temptation well when we're overcome by
temptation we will using the instrument
less strongly than we should in the face
of temptation and we will more strongly
for what it is that the temptation is
you know coercing or cajoling or
whatever excuse we make us into doing
and he's got a really wonderful analogy
here that I think helps to make sense of
it it's a physical one
right he talked about the case of here
we go
a man so strong that while he was
holding a wild bull the bull was unable
to get away so we're talking about a
very very strong man grabbing the bull
literally by the horns and the bull
can't get away
we know he's super strong we've measured
it now right
that's the
instrument then we see that same guy and
he's got a ram a much weaker creature
compared to a bowl still pretty strong
for the rest of us and the RAM is able
to get away from him we say what's going
on did he suddenly become weak is he no
longer as strong as he was no he didn't
use his strength as fully on the RAM as
he could have if he wanted to he could
have controlled the RAM just as easily
as he controls the bull perhaps even
more easily since the RAM is not as
strong of a creature something similar
is happening when we're posed with
temptation we have the strength with any
given temptation to grapple the horns
and hold fast its it may hurt it may not
feel good it may you know be boring it
may there could be all sorts of other
difficulties that arise but we do have
the capacity to deal with it and yet in
many cases grabbing the the RAM or even
let's make it even smaller a little
guinea pig right no horns at all we just
have to keep it from moving across the
room or a kitten or a puppy or a turtle
and suddenly it escapes our grasp well
that's because we did not use our
strength in the way that we could have
so when we're facing temptations and we
get into it it's not because there's a
failure in the will as instrument the
Willa's instrument remains the same it's
a failure in the will as use of that
instrument and it also involves another
use of that instrument giving in to
whatever the temptation happens to be so
that helps us to explain this puzzle we
are at the same time strong but we don't
use all of the strength that we could
use indeterminate choices and situations
you